and then you guys obviously created a
dope brand uh Henny palooza which toured
I mean for forever
yeah look yeah do say is it it's do you
say paloozing hours is it still a thing
it's not a thing no okay it's done I
don't know if I'm officially allowed to
say that but we're not we're not coming
back it's over yeah sorry if I we didn't
have like more of a
whole closing type thing but yeah we
ended at the Barclays
um that's a way seriously Jokes Aside
was a huge part of that and then also
after Kobe like we all got kind of old
like that [__] becomes exhausting when
you're traveling around the world
drinking yeah like a lot yeah um yeah it
becomes really really tiring so I mean
it was an ERA it was an incredible thing
I think it's in the lineage of
parties within the culture like I I
think it's up there in no way am I like
saying we're the tunnel but for our era
like that's a staple for our era as far
as what was going on in hip-hop at the
time with parties and I think we changed
how parties are now like the day party
is the thing now the Branded party is
the thing right the club that's the
thing the clubs are you know have been
dying I think they're trying to make a
comeback with these these new set of
kids yeah I just opened a club in
Scottsdale and it's like uh it's been
[__] great it's been amazing but you
know we've been lucky we kind of feel
there was no hip-hop clubs up in AZ so
we opened the spot and
open it right before Super Bowl whatever
happened to that Rapper Juice from he
goes by Richie Evans now he was really
dope still was dope Richie's dope he's
um
OG mugs my boy OG mugs manages him who's
like Tech Nine security and E40 security
and uh he just he just performed at
garyvee's V con
okay
a little different than Black Wall
Street but yeah he goes by Richie Evans
now he was dope I always like juice a
lot juice was dope yeah the black wasp
and then we had hot rod
who was signed a G-Unit and then we had
Willie northpole who was signed the
ludicrous I remember Willie North Pole
and of course I remember hot rod hot rod
had a record with Mary J he did it might
be easy and you know the thing about Hot
Rod is he still lives in Arizona he's
kind of like a social media like he runs
some funny pages and stuff shout out to
him I think his shit's good times
Jackson on Instagram but he was really
from Sacramento so Arizona really never
uh embraced him like that because he was
he was from Sacramento okay well he I
mean we all thought he was rep Daisy
that was a weird time in in G-Unit
super weird that was like when you could
you could tell it was like
you know I remember when I was super
excited that mop and MOB deep were on
G-Unit
I have money blood money was a decent
album there's no singles on there
um
MLP never dropped an album on G-Unit did
they not that I remember no but I I
thought even in my young naive time at
that when they signed mob deep I love
mob deep and I didn't think it was over
from Mob deep I just thought it was
weird that Jeanette was signing acts
older than them and I was like this is
odd the MLP signing and love MLP
Warriors is one of my favorite albums I
[__] love MLP
I just I was like this is cool like
shout out to as a kid I wasn't thinking
to myself like why is 50 signing guys
that are older than him and underground
is fun yeah I was just like this is lit
like I didn't think anybody was like the
MLP but me you know what I'm saying like
I just figured it was all some petty
[__] behind the scenes because wasn't
MLP on Rockefeller yeah then I think yes
and then there was something there was
some other G Unit
Petty beef that he also signed that
makes a lot of sense [__] you hoe I'm
signing an MLP By the Way That You Don't
Know Remix the only version of the song
I prefer yeah I agree blueprint too you
know what I mean I'm glad this is the
only podcast I can have juice
conversations on this is why sorry I
didn't come with my regular press run
[__] I just want to talk about juice
from Arizona Richie Evans
um